donc là je deviens complètement
schizophrène j'aime chez dreux la
monsieur-là monsieur-là messieurs dreux
là j'ai deux écrans sur mon ordinateur
dimanche grotte tous les côtés le son
qui est complètement superposés c'est
complètement fou
[Musique]
si vous avez suivi mes vidéos depuis le
mois de septembre voire depuis avant
j'espère vous avez vu que je parle plus
d'ordinateurs je m'intéresse vachement
problématique des pc savoir quel pc
achetés quel est le bon pc quel pc vaut
le coup quel pc vaut pas le coup du taux
en général je parle des pc que j'aime
bien plutôt de ce que j'aime pas c'est
d'ailleurs d'une manière générale pour
les produits que je teste d'ailleurs si
je suis souvent assez positif dans des
thèses c'est parce qu'en règle générale
je ne dirige pas vers des tests de
produits que je n'aime pas tout ça c'est
un petit peu classique et donc
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler à d'un
pc de la marque asus parce que si vous
n'avez suivi et j'en reviens à ce que je
faisais juste avant à prendre je veux
perdre dans mes pensées
c'est lorsque j'étais à berlin à l'ifa
j'étais aux asus media days les journées
asus les jo des presses des zus ou asus
nous présenter tout l'éventail de ses
nouveautés tous ces nouveaux produits et
je vous ai parlé déjà d'improvisation ce
que je trouve super content que je
trouvais vraiment tout a super cool
c'est hyper enthousiaste c'est le
zenbook pro d'asus avec quelques jours
maintenant que je l'utilisent en plus
avoir un design qui est assez sympa il a
plein de particularités et surtout il a
un trackpad qui est complètement
hallucinant je vais vous passez hyper-v
de la fiche technique de cette bécane
parce que c'est une bonne bécane
il ya plein de choses à dire dessus mais
c'est pas du tout le point essentiel le
point essentiel si vous avez déjà gagné
plusieurs vidéos sur produit ça situe
par ici ça je veux garde pour après on a
donc trois versions on a un intel core
i5 intel core i7 un intel core i9 on a
soit 8 gigas de ram sur les dettes core
i5 soit 16 giga de ram sur le i7 et le
n9 en termes de stockage on a du ssd
partout sur le heat 5 vous avez 2 156
giga sur le i7 vous avez 500 12 giga
alors que sur le enough
vous avez carrément un terreau a donc là
franchement vous avez de quoi faire il
tourne sous un windows pro ça c'est cool
et il a un écran 15,6 pouces full hd en
tout cas à la version j'ai ici parce
qu'a priori il existe une version aussi
avec de la 4k l'image de ce qui est
plutôt cool sur cet écran c'est qu'on
ait une vision quand même grand temps de
leur âge et l'éclairage en pleine
tronche mais vous pouvez vous décaler
sur le côté vous voyez vraiment de tous
les côtés de tous les bords donc ça
c'est plutôt cool et il ya vraiment un
très bon boulot qui fait là dessus de la
part d'asus clavier qui est complètement
rétro éclairé très agréable
le retour de touche franchement très
très bien ce qui est plutôt aussi sympa
là dessus c'est que vous avez un petit
capteur d'empreintes digitales
alors je sais pas si la position est
idéale parce que le bouton pour
l'allumer la tag on vous
lui mais vous déverrouillez bon vous
faites glisser votre doigt en fait pas
non plus les feignants clac clac paf
c'est parti autre point qui est
extrêmement coule au niveau du son vous
avez un sont certifiés harman kardon
ce qui veut dire une vraie qualité audio
et franchement ça avec l'absurde
induction qui est vraiment de qualité
alors ce qui est très intéressant avec
le son c'est que les haut parleurs
je montre ils sont situés de côté vous
avez un petit haut parleur qui est ici
et vous avez son frangin qui est ici de
l'autre côté donc on a du son qui vient
de chaque côté du son qui réfléchit par
votre sol qui va remonter là et vous
allez récupérer en pleine tronche vous
allez voir je mets une petite vidéo
franchement sans voix du bois
je trouve ça vraiment très très bon un
seul détail près là comme ça si vous
voulez poser votre ordinateur
directement sur vos genoux vous allez
venir un petit peu bloqué les haut
parleurs qui sont chaque côté dont votre
fonds va être un peu plus mate un peu
plus étouffée à côté de saab ont pété
les gens comme ça ça marche
voilà c'est un peu seul point négatif
parce qu'il fallait bien trouver une
critique à lire quand des menaces
ordinateur sinon on avait pensé que
j'étais un vendu donc le son est très
très doux alors n'a pas beaucoup
beaucoup de basse forcément les sont des
petits haut parleurs
par contre ce qui est vraiment bien
c'est avec la position est vraiment
vraiment bien réfléchi comme le poser
sur un support liste comme ça ça
réfléchit ça vous fait remonter le son
en sensations un peu plus immersive
c'est vraiment très bien fait et très
mal en tout cas de la part de l'accusé
de l'avoir fait comme ça on va pas loin
de mettre un petit peu de la carte
graphique vous avez une nvidia geforce
gtx 1050 avec 4 gigas de ram gddr5
franchement ça marche extrêmement bien
on a un windows 10 à l'intérieur c'est
un windows dix professionnels bonjour à
vous apprendre de bien dingue là dessus
ça marche bien des canes très fluide
très réactive pourrons pas continuer
cette partie technique avec la
connectique on a deux ports thunderbolt
3 usb type c on a 2 hdmi bon ici de quoi
recharger votre bécane de l'usb type à
un port microsd une prise jack
ce qui est vraiment cool ex et
connectique c'est vous pouvez brancher
plusieurs moniteurs avec du thunderbolt
3 avec 2 hd mais enfin ça c'est vraiment
coup on a pas mal de possibilités là
dessus je trouve qu'il y assez complète
en termes de connectique il ya ce qu'il
faut donc on est une machine performante
polyvalente
tout ça c'est cool mais c'est pas ça qui
fait la spécificité est l'origine était
de ce produit si vous en souvenez quand
on en a parlé à berlin l'idée
effectivement de cette machine
c'était vraiment d'aller réinventer avec
bousculer les codes niveau l'ordinateur
parce que ce qui avait été dit ce qui
est très juste c'est que des innovations
sur les pc y en a pas des masses souvent
pensé qu'un pc c'etait un pc à pc
portable c'est un pc portable avait pas
beaucoup d'innovations à porter et que
c'était relativement faux et justement
l'idée là-dessus cailles aux us c'est
d'apporter de l'innovation ici au niveau
de son trackpad avec ce qu'ils appellent
un scream pad c'est à dire un deuxième
écran ici et croyez-moi ça c'est
vraiment révolutionnaire
alors je sais tout de suite on dit
révolutionnaire le mot est hyper
galvaudé revolution little révolutionne
ça vous rappelle pas mal de chose par
contre je vous assure l'idée vraiment là
c'est à dire au lieu d'avoir un petit
tract pas tout simple qui vous sert un
peu de mulot au bout du dos
vous avez vraiment un vrai usage vous
avez vraiment quelque chose de super
vous avez un vrai écran à portée de
doigts ça vous créez des usages permet
d'avoir pas mal de raccourcis de faire
plus de choses d'aller plus loin et tout
ça dans une machine qui est franchement
bien parce que ce trackpad c'est bien
plus qu'une souris vous avez des
raccourcis ça c'est vraiment cool
raccourci pour de la musique pour la
vous avez votre lanceurs avec l'asus
vive box fournir télécharger différentes
applis je vous montrais pour l'utiliser
sur le screen pas directement
vous avez un calendrier tout ce sont des
raccourcis 1 pour l'ouvrir en eau sur
l'écran principal donc là vous le verrez
pas c'est relativement normal donc vous
avez vos mails de raccourcis vous pouvez
personnaliser et même rajouter vos
propres raccourcis sur un jeu sur une
application que vous préférez sur ce que
vous voulez donc ça c'est vraiment cool
vous avez aussi la possibilité d'avoir
votre pavé numérique parce que sur les
claviers 15 pouces vous n'avez pas de
pavé numérique
vous avez uniquement un clavier donc
comme ça vous laisser en permanence vous
avez ici votre pavé numérique vous avez
ici votre clavier
vous avez également spotify qui est là
vous avez votre calculatrice pour bien
faire des calculs extrêmement compliqué
un plus un égale ne pouvait faire aussi
de haut careï tu as très bien deux
occupants 8 vous pouvez venir aussi
complètement la paramétrer obtenir plus
d'applications personnalisées la barre
d'outils ce que vous allez mettre ici
dans votre lanceur vous allez pouvoir
régler votre luminosité à votre souhait
pour vous faire plaisir affiché le fond
d'écran oui ou non l'introduction voit
la fin il ya pas mal de petites
possibilités et c'est surtout
complètement personnalisable donc là ce
que je vous montre c'est un peu pour se
marrer parce qu'en réalité on peut faire
beaucoup plus de choses ça ça pas
uniquement d'avoir quelques raccourcis
quelques applications a lancé à bord de
seulement une calculatrice ou un pavé
numérique
c'est pas du tout ça on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin faire beaucoup plus
de choses
vous êtes ici dans votre ordinateur vous
vous dites tiens je me lançais par
exemple un petit pack office je me lance
un petit world vous ouvrez votre horde
là et vous avez tout de suite les
raccourcis world qui apparaissent ici
dans le screen pâle
vous allez donc pouvoir piloter world
depuis ici et ça franchement c'est cool
la même chose sur excel par exemple vous
allez taper un petit message up dans
votre excellent directement là où vous
savez le screen pas vous pouvez mettre
en gras en italique faire ce que vous
voulez comme vous voulez augmenter la
taille du texte 10 minutes et de la
police ça marche extrêmement bien donc
ça c'est bien c'est marrant mais sec le
début parce qu'en réalité vous pouvez
faire beaucoup plus de choses
vous expliquer le fonctionnement on va
reprendre à la base vous avez un petit
bouton qui est juste là et qui vous
permet de sélectionner différents modes
vous avez le mode screen pâte standard
c'est ce que vous avez ici vous avez le
mode affichage d'extension c'est un mode
vous avez un deuxième bureau qui se
trouve directement là et ça franchement
c'est hyper cool je vous montre ce qu'on
peut encore choisir et ensuite je vais
détailler sa l'autre c'est juste un
petit pavé tactile très classique pour
venir ensuite naviguer directement vous
avez un petit mulot très classique ça
marche très très bien et le dernier mode
votre pavé tactile est complètement
désactivé en gros vous pouvez
strictement plus rien faire avec
c'est franchement ballot donc le
deuxième mode le mode d'affichage
extension est vraiment super intéressant
parce que vous avez un écran de 5,5
pouces full hd en rose comme si vous
aviez un petit smartphone en guise de
trackpad disent parfois de plus parce
qu'en réalité ça vous fait un deuxième
bureau là pour tous à vous faire vous
raybaud deuxième écran intégré dans
cette bécane et franchement c'est génial
là tout est complètement hallucinant
vous avez votre ordinateur là et vous
avez votre ordinateur la voilà ça vous
c'est en gros deux ordinateurs en un
alors je vais vous montrer ce qu'on peut
faire avec par exemple le regarder une
vidéo sur youtube d'une chaîne que
j'aime beaucoup
bon par exemple par hasard si je veux
regarder en même temps mais puis bosser
faire autre chose gk venir ici j'appuie
sur mon petit menu et je mets windows
d'hommes et là je vais retrouver
directement ma vidéo du coup je les plus
hauts roger plus rien du tout je la
retrouve directement bas et ça c'est
vraiment génial
donc une fois que celui-là up j'aimais
le coeur sans mode que la mettre aussi
en mode plein écran
parce que franchement si beaucoup plus
sympa comme ça donc là ici c'est ma
première vidéo gmail sont g leçon j'ai
absolument rien là mais par contre j'ai
ma vidéo l'a ensuite ce que je vais
faire c'est utiliser maintenant ça en
version trackpad donc j'appuie là je
sors du touch mouse
ça me refais une petite souris et je
peux bien navigué l'a donc là maintenant
je suis en bas j'ai ma petite souris
orages pas si vous voyez bien dans mon
petit pointeur qui est là bas par
exemple je vais venir m'ouvrir 24 et
explorer juste l'attaquent jeu lourd et
il s'ouvre maintenant directement ici là
quand je bouge sur notre ipad ça bouge
uniquement en bas mais en auge
absolument qu un mulot donc ce que je
peux faire c'est prendre un petit sory
jaffe montée est comme ça hop et j'ai
directement mon petit mulot ici donc là
je peux me faire un trip et mettre une
deuxième vidéo que j'adore regarder
directement ici donc là je deviens
complètement schizophrène jemseg rela
monsieur-là maigreux la nuit suivre là
j'ai deux écrans sur mon nom
anna torv i must go tous les côtés le
son qui est complètement superposés
c'est complètement fou parce que c'est
ce qu'on peut faire alors là je le
pousse un petit peu extrême la gemmi
internet explorer avec une vidéo de
youtube en plein écran la gemmi google
chrome avec une vidéo en plein écran
je peux même aller encore plus loin je
quitte le votre plein écran je prends
hop ma vidéo et je le fais descendre en
bas mon contenu en bas nous ont contenu
en eau
je fais comme je veux je fais ce que je
veux je peux naviguer entre les deux
donc au final le petit fils pas d'ici
est un deuxième écran est une extension
mon premier écran ça fait comme un
deuxième bureau et franchement c'est
vraiment génial
un deuxième écran oui et non parce que
pour utiliser comme un deuxième écran
m'a déjà il faut quand même avoir de
bons yeux l'or après vous cliquer
n'importe où ça marche la regarder pour
faire défiler se fait à deux doigts ça
défile exactement de la même manière
c'est vraiment génial c'est hyper
intuitif c'est vraiment cool vraiment
vraiment cool
par contre il faut mettre des lunettes
prévoir une loupe ce que vous voulez que
ça c'est un petit peu le point de regret
là dessus fallait bien avoir un point de
regrets par rapport à ce screen pas que
je trouve vraiment génial je trouve que
il ya une vraie vraie vraie bonne idée
là dedans c'est de permettre à avoir
cette zone qui viennent une zone utile
et pas juste une zone pour faire
naviguer votre petit mulot par contre
lorsque vous le mettez comme ça on voit
vraiment pas grand chose on se fait un
peu mal aux yeux
on va pas rester longtemps dans ce mode
là lorsque vous l'utilisez dans le
premier mode ça marche extrêmement bien
c'est vraiment bien optimisé ce qu'il
faudrait très clairement dans le mode
d'affichage extension vous avez votre
petit ordinateur comme samba c'est un os
qui soit complètement adaptatif or
c'était des choses qu'on aura plus tard
un peu comment est ce que vous prenez
une tablette et que vous branchez avec
un clavier ça vous fait un ordinateur
sous windows disque d'avoir une partie
complètement adapté la aux screen pad
est ce qu a vu sur un partenariat avec
microsoft
là-dessus à l'avenir en tout cas ça
serait vraiment hyper pertinents ça
c'est le premier point de regrets mais
j'ai aussi un deuxième point de regret à
savoir que dans le catalogue en ligne
et bien vous n'avez pas beaucoup
d'applications vous pouvez installer sur
le screen pad
il en existe quelques unes mais y'en a
pas encore énormément de notre côté
c'est un produit qui est sorti il ya pas
hyper hyper hyper longtemps donc ça me
paraît pas anormale qui est pas encore
énormément de contenu là dessus parce
qu'il faut que des développeurs
travaillent là dessus pour proposer des
solutions complètement compatible avec
cette décade j'imagine que dès lors que
cette machine rencontrera un succès
commercial grandissant encore où une
énorme et bien à ce moment-là ça tirait
encore plus de développeurs à venir
développer directement pour le screen
pâle ça ne saurait tarder
mais au final ce qui n'est pas dit sert
à quoi il a vraiment un sens alors pas
forcément d'être regardé une vidéo sur
les écrans comme le zoom en douceur mais
on peut très bien imaginer vouloir
regarder une vidéo des clips un film une
série netflix ou ce qu'on veut
directement en bas sur fond d'écran et
sur la partie du haut à travailler sur
un projet devoir faire du traitement de
texte femme d'un contador ce que vous
voulez ça un vrai sens vous en train de
bosser sur un document un dossier très
important quelqu'un vous appelle vous
êtes en avoir accès tout de suite à
votre agenda et votre smartphone dans
votre main non attendez je me rends par
leur jeu mais un allié pour ce que je
voulais c'est pas pratique pour aider
directement soit au skins pad vous avez
accès à vous rendez vous ça c'est aussi
extrêmement pratique à 6 nous annonce
une autonomie allant à plus de neuf
heures 9h 9h30 très clairement la
machine en l'état comme elle est là les
9 heures vous les aurez pas tout
simplement parce que vous avez le screen
pas des deux crimes pad est vraiment
énergivores
ça me fait quand même un deuxième écran
à alimenter donc là franchement je vous
le dis tout de suite ça consomme
davantage si par contre vous avez une
utilisation hybride c'est-à-dire que
votre crime pad lorsque vous ne
l'utilisez pas vous le désactiver vous
allez gagner en autonomie
si vous laissez le script pas tout le
temps lui mais l'autonomie va diminuer
et c'est là que c'est moins intéressant
en gros on peut dire que le point
positif de cet ordinateur est au final
son point négatif à savoir que vous avez
un beau screen pad qui a un vrai sens
une vraie utilité mais par contre au
niveau autonomie ça le dessert
franchement à côté de ça il se recharge
très rapidement en moins d'une heure
vous l'avait chargé à plus de 60 % ce
qui fait que lorsque vous allez prévoir
des déplacements vous lui mettez une
bonne charge
ça va relativement vite et lorsque vous
êtes à la maison eh bien vous laisser
brancher sur le secteur comme ça ça
consomme pas vous n'avez qu'à le
débrancher vous partez et là vous êtes
parti vous êtes tranquille bon tout ça
c'est bien beau mais en termes de tarifs
comment situe alors j'ai tout noter que
je n'ai pas repris par coeur il ajouté 3
config principales versions i5 avec 256
giga de stockage en ssd vous êtes à
moins de 1300 euros vous êtes à 1299
euros pour la version i 7 512 giga de
stockage 1799 et sur la version ie9
intérêts vous êtes à 2999 euros alors
l'acheter ok mais pour quel usage
je vois trois petites deux profils
différents c'est déjà un nouvel
ordinateur pour la bureautique pour du
multimédia pour avoir un ordi
pour faire du traitement de texte des
emails bosser un peu prendre des cours
faire de la comptal choses comme ça vous
allez sur le modèle il 5
ça marche très bien vous mettez un peu
moins de 1300 euros vous aurez une
excellente machine le script c'est un
très très bon outil vous êtes tranquille
si maintenant vous voulez un peu plus de
puissance que vous faites un petit peu
de montage vidéo vous faites de la
retouche photoshop avec pas mal de
calques vous allez sur le vix 7 16 giga
de ram franchement ça fonctionnera très
très bien si maintenant vous êtes donc
plus de performances que voulait faire
de la 3d faire du montage quelqu'un
d'autre chose qui [ __ ] un peu plus
vous allez sur le 9 16 giga de ram un
terrain de stockage
franchement vous avez de quoi voir venir
vous serez vraiment tranquille la
question à se poser maintenant c est ce
que vous avez besoin d'un ultraportable
d'une machine avec une grosse autonomie
à emmener partout avec vous ils vont
rencontrer pas forcément de prises pour
le brancher régulièrement à ce moment là
je suis pas sûr que sur celui là qu'il
faille aller si par contre vous et une
machine polyvalente une très bonne
machine de bonnes fabrication avec les
dernières innovations qu'on peut avoir
en termes de pc avec de la performance
avec un screen pas qui franchement
magique
vous pouvez aller sur cette bécane vous
serez franchement pas déçu mon tout cas
je suis vraiment un amoureux ce screen
pâle je trouve que c'est vraiment un
outil qui est très pratique on fait
vraiment plein de choses avec ça ouvre
d'autres perspectives ça ouvre d'autres
horizons on pourrait imaginer encore
plein d'autres applications imaginez
lorsque vous faites du montage vidéo ce
que ça peut vous apporter lorsque vous
travaillez sous photoshop que peut vous
apporter énormément de choses donc on
peut imaginer vraiment un beau
développement à venir
on peut imaginer aussi que asus nous
sorte une deuxième version l'année
prochaine encore plus boosté avec plus
d'autonomie
ça serait vraiment presque l'ordinateur
à aider parce que je le trouve vraiment
bien et je dis ça je ne suis pas payée
par asus n'est pas une vidéo sponsorisés
je le pense vraiment une belle
innovation qui était déjà dessus et un
vrai bel effort sur les pc bâle dites
moi ce que vous en pensez comment vous
trouvez cet ordinateur de la zus est ce
qu'il vous plaît ce qui pourrait vous
plaire que vous l'avez déjà
est-ce que vous avez déjà des bécanes de
asus vous marquez tout ça en bas en
commentaire et une fois de plus vous
invite à vous abonner à rester connectés
et à suivre mais crytek sur la chaîne
soyez ça je vous embrasse
il ya très bientôt
[Musique]